foreign
not in the booth but Jenna in Madison
Wisconsin what's up Jenna
hey I'm good how are you good what's up
hey I just wanted to say thank you for
all your Insight tools and validation
that you've offer on your show it's um
invaluable so thank you for that thank
you so much what's up
um so my question is is how can one go
about family functions during the
holidays when things such as gift
exchange cannot be agreed upon to put
further emphasis on this we are on the
DV Dave Ramsey baby step two and I had
suggested to do a creative way else and
gifts with the low-cost with the kids to
make a fun game with it instead my
thoughts were completely surpassed with
my sister-in-law and she doesn't want to
skip the tradition and suggested to do
the usual 50 gift exchange in addition
to the white elephant
um this completely defeats my purpose of
my suggestions
I'm thinking about let's just do white
elephants like cool let's do that and
so I want to teach my kids like
contentment and the quality of family
time and I realize she won't change but
how do I navigate through this well
maintaining my own dignity and my
financial Journey
uh you you don't Outsource your dignity
that's yours don't give that to her
yeah dignity is I'm doing the best thing
long term for me and my family to keep
us safe
and for those listening who don't know
Dave Ramsey plan
um I'm a part of a team here at Ramsey
Solutions I work with Dave Ramsey who's
helped millions and millions of people
get their lives back and get out of debt
um and we may do a whole episode on the
mental health of debt it's just Madness
um and there's a series of baby steps
um and you're on baby step two which
means you are feverishly paying off
debts knocking out credit cards and
student loans and paying off car notes
and all that right
correct yes in a hard part of that is
the holidays is when you have to tell
your kids and your family hey we don't
have a ton of money for gifts this year
we're trying to change our lives and
become safe
and you sounds like you announced that
plan to your family and your
sister-in-law was like
um I want my gifts
up with the Joneses
um you know brand name the new car that
um it was really difficult because in
the past two whatever gifts I've gotten
they've already have or have it in a
different color cool hey here's the deal
here's the deal here's the deal you know
it's hard it is but it's super not this
is a great moment for you unhook any
sort of
comparison with them uh you're running a
race anymore
you know what I mean like Let's Race I'm
not I'm not racing you
one of my greatest lessons I learned at
the MMA gym is I used to walk around all
the time like we got a problem bro I was
that guy what an idiot and then I got
worked over I got my head kicked in just
beat in by a male nurse named Mateo I'll
never forget him he was incredible great
guy two little kids he was about five
six we had about 155 pounds and he was a
boxer and he beat me stupid and I
remember thinking if I'd been at any
little bar or restaurant I would have
been like hey we got a problem bro and I
woke up would have woke up three days
later in the ER right and what it did is
it humbled me
I quit walking around being like hitch I
don't care
like I just want to have a good life
right and so if if you am I in a
restaurant you want to fight me I'm J
here I'm gonna buy you a drink because
you're clearly having a bad day and I'm
gonna head on to the next place I'm out
and if you're like your kids hey have a
great day have a great day I'm just out
right I'm completely unhooked myself
from that and so this is a great
practice for you right now
you could tell your sister-in-law feel
free to buy all the gifts you want we're
not doing that
and if somebody wants to buy gifts for
your kids you can't absorb that shame as
though you're a failure as a mom because
you didn't buy those gifts too
yeah I think there's a lot of guilt with
it my sister regularly buys more gifts
for my kids than we do and I love it
my sister doesn't have any kids of her
own she is a great Gift Giver it's
incredible dude and I love it bring it
on
because I'm not competing does that make
sense
right I'm not competing I'm not in a
competition I love my sister I love my
kids and rock it on and if I were to
call and reach out and say hey nobody
buy gifts this year my family wouldn't
I'm so I don't have a bunch of yeah I'm
not in your same situation but you've
made your boundary clear and here's your
two choices let me just get to that two
choices
we're not coming
and that's a viable Choice don't go
just don't go right or go and if
somebody's gonna be a jerk and hand out
50 gifts to everybody that's great we
didn't do gifts this year just like we
said we weren't
[Applause]
needed to have um ear surgery and so as
soon as I could get her in was on a
Friday and I happened to be the Friday
before of a weekend of my nephew's
birthday party and they live two and a
half hours away and so I had said like
you know we're not gonna be able to come
she's having surgery that Friday which
would work out great because then
hopefully she can go back to school on
Monday and she's like you need to change
that to Monday you're coming to his
birthday party I'm like no no no I'm not
and um and then the weekend came and
she's like hey um are you guys coming
I'm like no I said I wasn't a month ago
you know so it's like that that she
doesn't accept the no and we where's
your husband on this
so my my husband
um suggested to be passively cordial in
order to not create a rift with his
brother she's been doing this career
are very close and and she's just this
and everybody in the family just says oh
that's just who she is that's just who
she is okay okay hold on hold on hold on
that is okay cool that's just who she is
and now you have a choice
are you gonna let just who she is run
your life or are you gonna say well this
is just how I am
me and my kids don't go to these things
because here's a deal Jenna she doesn't
get a vote in your life quit giving her
a vote
right tell your husband
he needs to suck it up and talk to his
brother or he needs to be making the
phone calls to his brother hey we're not
coming to this thing
cool man
because if he had called his brother and
said hey one of my kids having surgery
we're not going to make your kids
birthday party this two and a half hours
away
um okay what a weird world we live in
dude
I I can't I'm gonna make it
um his brother would have said that's
cool man
right
I
I would have because I think his
brother's crazy going now so maybe you
tell your husband hey from this point
forward you're making the phone calls
I'm not doing this anymore
because I'm talking to somebody who is
not interested in listening to us
and if you're not interested in making
those calls to your brother when we have
to say hey we're trying to pay off debt
so this year Christmas is going to look
different for us
if you're not interested in making that
call great I'm not going
sure right
right is the magic word boundaries you
get to choose them it is it is well and
and
it's um
here's why you're frustrated yeah
because you've allowed this to go on
stop
you you you are now no longer frustrated
at her
you have an imaginary fantasy picture of
what you wanted this life to look like
and it doesn't look like that
and you're getting more and more
frustrated at you
because you're not setting boundaries
your husband's not stepping up to deal
with his brother and say hey man
everyone in the family is just rolling
over and letting this woman take over
every and stop
end the frustration choose guilt over
resentment every time
instead of just going along and spending
money you guys don't have and putting
yourselves in your family on even more
thin ice financially
which is going to cause you to resent
her resent Christmas resent the
Gathering resent everything
I'm not giving you that I'm going to
choose guilt hey we're not going to come
we're just not going to make it this
year it's cool
and if she chooses to throw a grown-up
temper tantrum that's how she chooses
that's her choice that's not I'm not
that's I'm not doing that I must not
doing that right so let her do her thing
let her do her thing unhook it
unhook yourself from her judgment the
Joneses judgment the neighbor's judgment
nobody gets a vote except for who you
allow
I'm just going to quit being frustrated
by other people man they don't have that
kind of power in my life